إنه نوع من هذه الحلقة الضحلة ، ثم
في منتصفها يوجد
ثقب مظلم عميق ينخفض ​​آه مئات
الأمتار
[موسيقى]
لذا فإن Blue Hole هو في الأساس ما
يبدو وكأنه
ثقب أم عملاق على حافة  الشاطئ وله في
الواقع القليل من
السمعة لأنه لسوء الحظ
فقد الكثير من الناس حياتهم هناك
لأنه يوجد
هذا القوس عندما تنزل ، لست
متأكدًا تمامًا من العمق ولكن عندما تتخطى
الطريق حيث يجب عليك  من أجل
الغوص الترفيهي ، يوجد قوس في
الحفرة يؤدي إلى المحيط ، لذلك
يحاول الكثير من الناس دفع أنفسهم
للنزول إلى هناك وللأسف
فقد الكثير من الناس حياتهم ، لذلك
يُعرف باسم موقع الغوص المذهل هذا
ولكنه أيضًا  يُعرف Blue Hole بأنه أحد أكثر
مواقع الغوص دموية في العالم
جيدًا لأنه
يحتوي على كل هذه العناصر ،
فهو يحتوي على نوع من المجهول العميق
أدناه حيث يتحول إلى اللون
الأزرق الداكن العميق وليس مثل الغوص على
الشعاب المرجانية حيث  يمكنك أن ترى الجزء السفلي ،
إنه مجرد جدار يسقط
منك تشعر وكأن هناك انفتاحًا معينًا
عليه وعمق معين له ولكن
في نفس الوقت يمكنك رؤية كل هذه
الحياة المذهلة على طول الجدار وعلى طول
الشعاب المرجانية التي  هل هناك الكثير
من الأسماك والكثير من
الأسماك التفاعلية حقًا هناك في الواقع
لا تخاف من سمعة
Blue Hole كما قلت إنه
موقع غوص آمن تمامًا طالما أنك
تتبع الإرشادات و  تعليمات
من معلمك أو Dive Master
واه لا تريد أن تفوتك هذا الموقع
لأنه حقًا جوهرة في مصر
قريب جدًا من المحاور ، لذا أشجع
كل من هو غواص على الذهاب إلى
دهب والتحقق من ذلك
[  موسيقى]